[موسيقى]
وفر الغاز للشتاء امن هذا عنوان خطه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه العام الماضي لمواجهه
الاضطرابات في امدادات الغاز الروسي بفعل
العقوبات المتبادله بين روسيا ودول
الاتحاد الاوروبي اثر الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا تجاوزت اوروبا الازمه في
امدادات الغاز والطاقه الشتاء الماضي
وخفضت استهلاكها للغاز وباتت تستورد ما
يمثل حوالي ثلث مستويات وارداتها
التاريخيه منه ونجحت اوروبا سريعا في
تنويع مواردها من الغاز وملئ خزاناتها
العام الماضي بتكلفه بلغت اكثر من 50
مليار دولار وفق المفوضيه الاوروبيه الا
ان ارتفاع تكاليف الطاقه كبت القاره
العجوز قرابه تريليون دولار نتيجه حزم
المساعدات التي قدمت للمستهلكين والشركات
وفق وكاله هذه الايام يظهر الاوروبيون
تفاؤلا بملا خزاناتهم للشتاء المقبل
فاسعار الغاز الطبيعي تشهد تراجعا الا ان
اطلقت من كبار المصدرين في الخليج ومن
خبراء في مجال الطاقه لاوروبا من ان
القادم قد يكون اسوا وان الوقت لا يزال
بعيدا قبل الاعلان عن انتهاء ازمه الطاقه
العالميه في قصتنا حرب الغاز نرصد تطور
مراحل اعتماد اوروبا على الغاز الروسي
وتاثره بالتوترات الروسيه الاوكرانيه بعد
انتهاء الحرب البارده ثم بالغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا نناقش مع خبراء عالميين في مجال
الطاقه بدائل اوروبا للحد من الاعتماد على
واردات الغاز الروسي سواء عبر الاستيراد
من الولايات المتحده او قطر او اذربيجان
او دولي اسيا الوسطى او افريقيا او غازي
شرق المتوسط وكذا التحديات التي تواجه
الاعتماد على اي بديل من هذه البدائل على
المدى البعيد نستكمل بقيه هذه القصه مع
الدكتور انس الحجي الباحث والخبير الدولي
في مجال الطاقه والسيده جولفيرا كبيره
الباحثين في معهد او سفرد لدراسات الطاقه
نسال ضيفين الكريمين عن امكانيه استغناء
اوروبا تماما عن واردات الغاز الطبيعي من
روسيا ومدى تاثر روسيا نفسها بالوضع
الراهن وهي تمتلك اكبر احتياطي في العالم
من الغاز الطبيعي وعن المدى الزمني اللازم
لتجاوز اوروبا ازمه الطاقه هذه وعن
العوامل المؤثره في اسواق الطاقه لكن قبل
ان نناقش كل هذا لنشاهد القصه اولا
خلال حقبه الحرب البارده ومع تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي حرصت برلين على ابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه مع موسكو وتدعيم العلاقات
الاقتصاديه معها وبرز الغاز الطبيعي في
مقدمه مساحات التقاطع الروسي الالماني حيث
قدمت برلين واحد واثنين من عشره مليون طن
من الانابيب التي استخدمتها موسكو لبناء
شبكه خطوط غزها الى اوروبا
تم توقيع اول عقول الغاز بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي واوروبا الغربيه عام 69 وقد بدا
تدفق الغاز منذ ذلك الحين
بلغت صادرات الغاز من روسيا الى اوروبا
ذروتها في عام 2008 بمعدل 170 مليار متر
مكعب عبر شبكه ممتده تغطي 40% من احتياجات
اوروبا من الغاز الطبيعي تمر معظمها عبر
اوكرانيا كدوله مرور رئيسيه
[موسيقى]
تمتلك اوكرانيا احد اكثر انظمه خطوط
انابيب الغاز تكاملا ويمكنها عمل الكثير
باستخدام خطوط الانابيب هذه انها بنيه
تحتيه قويه جدا واصبحت منفذا اساسيا لدخول
اوروبا الغربيه واجزاء من اوروبا الشرقيه
ايضا وتدفق الغاز الروسي عبرها دون توقف
[موسيقى]
عندما اعلنت اوكرانيا الاستقلال منذ ذلك
الحين بدات الصراعات بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وروسيا بطبيعه الحال كانت روسيا تعتبرها
دائما ساحه خلفيه لم تكن تريد ان ترحل
وتفقد السيطره عليها
يناير كانون الثاني عام 2009 تم وقف امداد
الغاز الى اوروبا نتيجه خلاف بين روسيا
واوكرانيا ما تسبب في ازمه حقيقيه لاوروبا
التي كانت تمثل خطوط اوكرانيا 80% من
الغاز الروسي الوارد لها
لا يمكنني تفسير اعتماد اوروبا ليس اوروبا
باكملها ولكن لماذا اعتقدوا انه من
المناسب الاعتماد على مصدر واحد لسد
احتياجاتهم من الطاقه
في عام 2020 انتجت اوروبا باكملها
218.6 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز الطبيعي في
حين استهلكت 541 وواحده من عشره مليار متر
مكعب دفع هذا اوروبا لاستيراد 326 وواحد
من عشره مليار متر مكعب من الغاز لتغذيه
عجز الاستهلاك
مع انخفاض الانتاج الاوروبي من الغاز زاد
الطلب على الغاز الروسي اكثر الذي كان ذا
تكلفه تنافسيه عاليه لذا فقد تركمت على
مدى سنوات عديده وحتى وقت قريب هي كما
اقول علاقه بنيت على مصالح مشتركه غاز بدا
يكون عنصر مهم جدا
في التنميه الاقتصاديه
واعتمادهم محطات وخاصه محطات الكهرباء
والتدفئه
فلذلك يعني اوروبا زادت طلب على الغاز
بشكل كبير جدا
وروسيا قريبه الى اوروبا روسيا هي اكبر
دوله منتجه
ولديها اكبر احتياطات غاز في العالم
تملك روسيا اكبر احتياطي للغاز في العالم
بنحو
19.9% وانتجت في عام 2020 نحو
مليار متر مكعب صدرت منها
متر مكعب وبرزت روسيا في عام 2021
كاكبر مورد للغاز الطبيعي الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
تنطلق شبكه امدادات الغاز من روسيا الى
اوروبا عبر مجموعه من الخطوط تمر اربعه
منها عبر اوكرانيا وتشكل هذه الخطوط اكبر
ممر لنقل الغاز الروسي بسعه تصميميه تقترب
من 100 مليار متر مكعب سنويا
استحوذت عمليه نقل الغاز عبر اوكرانيا على
26% من الغاز المرسل من روسيا ويبلغ معدل
رسوم عبور الغاز الروسي لاوكرانيا دولارين
و66
مقابل كل مليون متر مكعب لكل 100 كم وهي
التكلفه الاعلى اوروبيه
بطبيعه الحال قررت روسيا تنويع طرق توصيل
الغاز لذلك ولدت فكره بناء خطوط الغاز
بدون دول عبور والتي تصل مباشره الى السوق
الاوروبيه
كانت الفكره هي وقف ارسال الغاز عبر
الطريق البري لاخراج اوكرانيا من المعادله
كطريقه لمعاقبتها والانتقال مباشره الى
المانيا لتصبح اول ميناء لوصول الغاز
يمتد خط نورد ستريم واحد المزدوج بطول
1224 كيلو مترا عبر بحر البلطيق من روسيا
الى المانيا ولديه القدره على نقل 55
مليار متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي يوازيه النردستريم 2
والذي يستطيع النقل 55 مليار متر مكعب
اضافي الا ان المانيا اعلنت ايقاف البدء
بنقل الغاز عبرديستريم 2 بعد اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اما خط يمان فقد اوقفت روسيا ضخ الغاز فيه
منذ عام 2021
وكان ينقل الغاز عبر بيلاروسيا بطول اربعه
الاف ومائه وسبعه كيلو متر وقدره
استيعابيه 33 مليار متر مكعب في السنه
واخيرا خط التورك ستريم والذي يبلغ طوله
930 كيلومترا ويمتد عبر البحر الاسود
وينقل احدى وثلاثين وخمسه من عشره مليار
متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا الى تركيا وجنوب
شرق اوروبا
[موسيقى]
مشهد طاقه في اوروبا عام 2023 مختلف تماما
عما كان عليه قبل عام تاريخيا اكثر من 45%
من واردات الغاز كانت تاتي من روسيا
للدول الاوروبيه وقعت مع روسيا لتزويده
بلقاس وهذا شيء يعني منطقي اذا
يعني انت تروحين اكبر دوله منتجه غاز
واكبر دوله عندها احتياطات راس في العالم
اوروبا المعتمده اعتماد كلي شبه كلي على
الغاز الروسي ما كان عندها تنوع في
المصادر
الاعتماد على سوق واحد خطر جدا
يختلف اعتماد دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه على
الغاز الروسي حيث اعتمدت اغلب دول الاتحاد
الاوروبيه على روسيا في اكثر من نصف
اجمالي وارداتها من الغاز الطبيعي
[تصفيق]
الوحدات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بعد اندلاع الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
عام 2022 فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي عده عقوبات
ضد موسكو
[موسيقى]
في مايو 2022 اغلقت شركه غاز بروم خط
انابيب الغازي امان ثم اوقف الضخ الغازي
عبر خط غاز النورد ستريم واحد قبل ان
يتعرض لاحقا لتفجيرات مما وضع اوروبا امام
مازق لتعويض الغاز الروسي رشا
[موسيقى]
اوروبا الان الغاز من خلال خط عبور واحد
فقط عبر اوكرانيا حيث يمر حوالي 42 مليون
متر مكعب فقط كل يوم
تعرف روسيا اهميه الغاز الطبيعي جيدا
واستخدامه كسلاح وستستخدمه كذلك من الان
فصاعدا
يشكل الغاز مورد طاقه رئيس في اوروبا مما
شكل ازمه في تلك القطاعات من المؤكد ان
عددا من الدول تعتمد بشكل كبير على الغاز
الروسي لصف فقط في المنازل ولكن كذلك في
التصنيع
مشكله الحقيقيه هي اننا اذا لم نتمكن من
الحصول على امدادات كافيه من الغاز من
مصادر اخرى فسيكون لدينا شتاء بارد وستصبح
الامور اكثر صعوبه
ندعم مواطنين بتخفيض فواتير الطاقه ندعم
كذلك الاقتصاد والصناعه والشركات الصغيره
سنفعل كل ما يجب لمواجهه الوضع الحالي
كثيرا على الاقتصاد العالمي لان اوروبا
جزء كبير من هذا الاقتصاد وهي تعاني الان
من ارتفاع التضخم وتهديدات الركود
الاقتصادي
لما هم يصير عندهم تضخم يجينا احنا احنا
ما نخلق التضخم
لذلك العالم العربي
يتاثر بسرعه
ما تتاثر به الدول
يعني الدول الاقتصاديه الكبرى
بالنسبه لنا فان اوروبا هي السوق الرئيسي
لمبيعات الغاز ويعد الوضع اكثر تعقيدا مع
الغاز حيث لا يمكن تغيير اتجاه خطوط
انابيب وهي ذات تكلفه عاليه كما لا توجد
وحدات تكفي لتسهيل تلك الكميه من الغاز
لذلك هذه الضربه اقتصاديه كبيره لنا كما
ان واردات الغاز تمثل جزءا كبيرا من
الميزانيه الفيدراليه التي لا نريد ان
نخسرها
تتمثل خيارات موسكو الحالي في حرق الغاز
في الهواء او اغلاق حولها ولذا تحاول
روسيا البحث عن بدائل كتوفير الغاز عبر
تركيا
[موسيقى]
في الاحتفاظ بحصتها في السوق الاوروبي
لكننا نفهم ان العلاقات لن تكون كسابق
هناك الان مفاوضات مع تركيا لانشاء مركز
التوزيع وسنحتاج الى اجراء حوار مع
الاوروبيين انفسهم في مرحله ما
المشكله التي لدينا الان هي ان هذا الشريك
غير جدير بالثقه يرفع السلاح ويستخدم
طاقتك اداه ابتزاز ضد الاقتصاد الاوروبي
بهدف تقسيمنا هذا شريك لا نريد التعامل
معه بعد الان وان كنا في اشد الحاجه لهذا
الغاز
في الخامس من اغسطس 2022 وافق المجلس
الاوروبي على خطه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لتوفير الغاز لشتاء امن ضمن مجموعه من
الخطوات الاجرائيه
خطتنا تسمى
وهي من ثلاثه اجزاء ايجاد امدادات بديله
من بلدان اخرى توفير المزيد من الطاقه
والعمل على تسريع استثماراتنا في الطاقه
المتجدده ستستخدم بعض دولنا الفحم اكثر
مما كانت تخطط له هذا الشتاء وقد يستخدم
البعض الطاقه النوويه لفتره اطول سنشهد
المزيد من حرق الفحم وهذا لا يتوافق مع
خطه المناخ الخاصه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
وفي سبيل تخفيف اوروبا اعتمادها على الغاز
الروسي لا يبدو انها امام الكثير من
الخيارات
الذكيه في وقت مبكر فقد وقع اتفاقيات مع
الكثير من منتجي الغاز المسال في الولايات
المتحده 50% من الغاز الذي يصل الان الى
اوروبا هو من المنتجين الامريكيين
يمثل الغاز المسال ثلاثه 33% من واردات
الغاز الاوروبي ويتطلب نقله تحويله الى
الحاله السائله عند سالب 160 درجه ثم نقله
بناقلات بحريه واستقباله في محطات تحوله
مجددا الى الحاله الغازيه وتعيد ضخه عبر
الانابيب ولا توجد في اوروبا سوى 25 محطه
للغاز المسال اوروبا بدات اوروبا في
التحول الى الغاز الطبيعي المسال من
الولايات المتحده بدلا من الغاز الروسي
لكن لا ينبغي ان ننسى ان هذا الغاز ذو
قدره معينه غير المحتمل ان تعوضه الواردات
الامريكيه فقط
وجهت الولايات المتحده
68% من صادراتها من الغاز الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبريطانيا خلال الاشهر الخمسه
الاولى من 2022 الا ان التكلفه العاليه لا
كونه بديلا محتملا في المستقبل وهي ذات
العقبه التي تواجه خيار الغاز القطري
والذي تصر الدوحه ان يكون بعقود طويله
الاجل السبب الذي يجعل قطر تطلب عقودا
طويله الغاز الى اوروبا هو التكلفه
الاوليه
الغاز نحن نتحدث عن مليارات الدولارات
لا نؤمن بالعقود القصير يجب ان يكون لهم
عندهم عقود طويله الاجل
والنهي هذه هي اللي بتخلي التوازن
والاستمراريه في انتاج الطاقه في دولهم
لذلك المانيا جاءت اخيرا
[موسيقى]
ووقع 15 سنه
لكن مشكلتهم انهم ما يسمى بالدول المسدوده
اي ديد لوك ما عندهم بحر لا يستطيع ان
يسير الغاز والى انا ما عنده بحر صدره وال
لازم هذا الباب يكون يعني طويل جدا ويمر
بدول مختلفه فهذا هي الدول طبعا محكومه
بالجغرافيا اذا اراد الاوروبيون ان تزودهم
اذربيجان بكميات اضافيه فانهم بحاجه الى
الاستثمار وتوسيع خطوط انابيب الغاز هناك
نضع الشراء
لتعويض الغاز الروسي فان الامر الاكثر
حكمه هو زياده المعروض من الموارد المتاحه
اولا كان نرويج والجزائر جزائر
الجزائر تزود اوروبا بالغاز عبر خطوط
انابيب الغاز المشكله مع الجزائر هي مدى
قدرتها على زياده الانتاجشن
يعد البحر الابيض المتوسط موطنا
لاحتياطيات الغاز التي يمكن ان تغذي
اوروبا لسته وسبعين عاما مقبلا
لقد وقعوا اتفاقيات مع مصر واسرائيل
للحصول على غاز اسمد عبر اليونان
ما رايناه في الواقع هو ان شركاء حول
البحر الابيض المتوسط يعملون معا بشكل
بناء لمساعده اوروبا في تجاوز الازمه لقد
وقعنا على مذكره تفاهم ثلاثيه بين اوروبا
لجلب الغاز من شرق المتوسط الى الموانئ
المصريه ثم اعاده تصديرها كغاز الى اوروبا
تشير وكاله الطاقه الدوليه الى وجود خمسه
تريليونات متر مكعب من الاحتياطيات غير
المطوره في افريقيا وقد بدات نيجيريا في
تجديد خطوطها لربطها بالمغرب والجزائر
بهدف نقل غازها الى ايطاليا واسبانيا
يتجه الغاز من افريقيا الى اوروبا الان
لكن الغاز القادم من نيجيريا عليه ان يقطع
مسافات طويله جدا لذلك كلما مرت خطوط
الانابيب عبر بلدان اكثر فانها ستكلف
نفقات كبيره من حيث الاستثمار وثانيا
ستحتاج الى عشرات الاتفاقيات التي يجب ان
تعقد عبر البلدان التي تمر بها
ازمه طاقه عالميه تغير خارطه شبكات الطاقه
وسيناريوهات يبدو ان ايا منها لا يمثل حلا
عاجلا لاوروبا
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفين
الكريمين معنا من دالاس دكتور انس الحاجي
الباحث والخبير الدولي في مجال الطاقه ومن
لندن جولفيرا
الباحثين في معهد اوكسفورد لدراساتي
الطاقه الاعلنا نبدا معك دكتور غازي ايفا
نتساءل حقيقه اوروبا تجاوزت ازمه الطاقه
تمكنت من ذلك الشتاء الماضي لكن تطلق الان
تحذيرات بان القادم قد يكون اسوا الشتاء
القادم كيف ترى اوروبا
الاوضاع موسطه ربما موجه من التفاؤل
ابدتها المفوضيه الاوروبيه حول هذا
الموضوع كيف تبدو لك مختلف المواقف بناء
على هذه التصريحات وبتحليل الواقع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يزال في حاله تعاف من
ازمه تاريخيه وذلك بسبب
القطاع امدادات الغاز الروسي التي بدات في
2021 في الوقت الحالي يبدو بان السوق هو
في حاله تعافي من هذه الصدمه لكن ربما قد
اكون منتبهه لبعض المخاطر التي ربما قد
تتفاقم بسبب ربما انقطاع المزيد من توريد
الغاز في السنه او سنتين القادمتين لكن
لابد كذلك ان نعي ان الشتاء قادم قريبا
وبالتالي فان الوضع مجددا حتى يغير في فصل
الشتاء لكن الامر يعتمد على عوامل متعدده
الاول هو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحتاج ان
يؤمن موارد الغاز من مصادر بديله من خلال
مسارات جديده بما في ذلك من خلال
العدد من الطرق المختلفه خصوصا عندما
يتعلق الامر بالغاز المسال وبالتالي
الاتحاد الاوروبي لابد ان يكون جاهزا
بالنسبه للمنافسه مع اسيا بالنسبه للغاز
المسال هنا نتحدث عن المنافسه فيما يخص
الاسعار في الوقت الذي يكون فيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي هو
السوق الاساسي بالنسبه للغاز المسال لكن
هذا السوق لا يشكل توازنا مع الاسواق
الاخرى وبالتالي فان هذا قد يقود الاسعار
الى اتجاه معين خلال هذا الصيف وبالتالي
تؤدي الى طلب متزايد في اوروبا على الغاز
المسال اعتقد ان
بعض موردي الغاز المسال يفضلون منتجون
الغاز المسال يفضلون السوق الاوروبي لكن
يعتمد على الطلب الموجود في اسيا وسوق
الغاز الموسال في اسيا اذا كانت المواردون
للغاز الطبيعي تحديدا في منطقه الخليج
سمعنا ذلك في قصتنا الليله يريدون عقودا
طويله الاجل وليس عقود قصيره الاجل التحول
انس الحجي دكتور يعني ما المعطيات
باعتقادك التي ادت الى اطلاق هذه
التحذيرات بان الازمه ليست خلف اوروبا
لكنها امامها سمعنا ذلك من العديد من
الخبراء في الطاقه مسؤولين كبار في الخليج
وحتى الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
نعم في البدايه نحن حتى من العام الماضي
في منشورات الشركه كنا نتكلم عن هذا
الموضوع من العام الماضي والاشباب واضحه
تماما انه لا يمكن التعويض عن الغاز
الروسي الناس يجب ان تعرف ان بحدود 20%
الان من واردات الاتحاد الاوروبي
واوكرانيا تاتي من روسيا 20% لا يمكن
التعويض عنها باي شكل من الاشكال
الاشكاليه الاخرى ان نحن الان علينا ان
نتذكر ان ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا بدات في
بدايه صيف 2021 يعني قبل الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا بعده شهور وبدات في الصيف
بعباره اخرى ان امامنا الصيف الان وقد
تكون المشكله في الصيف
كبيره ايضا لماذا اعطيك مثال سيناريو واضح
تماما هناك شيف اذا كان هناك شيف حار في
اوروبا هناك ازمه كبيره في خليج المكسيك
الاعاصير التي بدا موسم الاعاصير الان كل
الصادرات الامريكيه التي تذهب الى اوروبا
من الغاز الميثال والتي تمثل 50% من
واردات الغاز المسالم الاوروبيه كلها تاتي
من خريج المكسيك اذا هذه الاعاصير منعت
هذه الشحنات حتى حتى المخزون العالي لن
يساعد اوروبا في هذه الحاله واذا كان
مشاكل الحرب امتدت الى اسيا فالمشكله
ستصبح كبيره جدا لانه في ذلك الوقت سيذهب
الغاز المثال لانه كله في عقود فوريه وليس
في عقود طويله المدى سيذهب الى من يدفع
اكثر
والصينيون سيدفعون اكثر
اعود اليك السيده وقد سمعت ما ذكره
الدكتور الحجي يعني هل هي مجرد حلول مؤقته
ربما انتهجتها هذه الدول الاوروبيه التي
نجحت صحيح في الواقع لتخفيض الاستيراد من
الغاز الروسي الى 15 بالمئه لكن التكل فه
ستكون عاليه جدا وهي مجرد بدائل مؤقته
ليست صالحه للمدى البعيد والسؤال اذا يعني
ماذا عن خياراتها امام ذلك باعتقادك
اذا هناك بالتاكيد بعض الخيارات لدى
اوروبا وهي موجوده على الطاوله عدا عن
الغاز الطبيعي الذي تحدثت عنه سابقا هناك
بعض موردين الذين بامكانهم ان يوفروا
المزيد من الغاز بالنسبه للاسواق
الاوروبيه ونتحدث
بامكانها عفوا عفوا بامكانهم بالفعل يعني
اوروبا بامكانها
تعدد الموردين وبامكانها فعلا الحصول على
ذلك لكن ماذا عن التكلفه
التكلفه
كم سيكلفها ذلك
[موسيقى]
كما قلت هي تزود الاسواق الاوروبيه بالغاز
باسعار السوق هذا لا يعني ان هذا الغاز
سيكون اكثر كلفه مقارنه باسعار الاوروبيه
الحاليه او ربما اعلى من الاسعار الموجوده
في المراكز الاساسيه التي هي المعيار
الاوروبي الاسعار او صناديق تي تي اف
اوروبا
اتفقا على ان يضاعف التوريد من عشره بي سي
ام الى 20 بي سي ام اسعار الغاز من الى
اوروبا هذه الاسعار ستكون اسعار السوق
التي تدفعها اوروبا حاليا بالنسبه لاي غاز
اخر ياتي من مصادر اخرى بما في ذلك الغاز
الروسي وبما في ذلك الغاز الطبيعي
لا اعتقد ان الغاز الذي سياتي من دول مثل
اذربيجان ربما قد يكون اكثر كلفه مما
تدفعه اوروبا حاليا بالنسبه للغاز الروسي
او اي غاز اخر هناك خيار اخر الا وهو
الغاز الذي ياتي من دول شمال افريقيا مثل
الجزائر وليبيا التي هي تورد اصلا الى دول
اوروبيه مثل ايطاليا واسبانيا
وتوفر لها الغاز من خلال اربع اربعه
انابيب هذه المصادر البديله هي غير
المصادر الروسيه وبالتالي هي بدائل لكنها
تحتاج الى طمانه الاسواق على انها ستكون
قادره على تطوير مصادر اذا كان مصادر عفوا
اذا كان هناك
الى ذلك اذا كان هناك اي تحيز مثلا في
حاله اذربيجان حتى يكون هناك استثمارات
بمليارات الدولارات في اصول جديده في
اذربيجان في مرحله ما بعد الانتاج فان
الشركات المنتجه للغاز وحكومه
تحتاج ان تؤمن الطلب لمدن طويل مما يعني
انها ستحتاج ان تكون قادره على
استقطاب الاستثمارات من مصارف الدوليه
ومؤسسات ماليه هذا يتطلب من
الجهه التي ستقوم بالشراء بان تتعاقد من
خلال عقود طويله الامد حتى يكون هناك
طمانه لهذه الدول من هذه الاسواق التي
تحتاج ان تلتزم من خلال عقود طويله الامد
لسوء الحظ الاتحاد الاوروبي حاليا هو في
ثنائيه صعبه لماذا لانهم يقومون بانتاج
سياسات اهداف صفريه من حيث الانبعاثات في
2040 و200 وفي الان ذاته هم لديهم مشاكل
تتعلق بتامين الغاز الطبيعي المسال وهذا
يشكل ازمه كبيره وربما قد تكون هناك ازمه
طاقه في الشتاء القادم
2025 ولهذه الاسباب فان
الاوروبيين والمقاربه التي يعتمدونها في
هذا الاطار من اجل الحصول على مصادر جديده
للغاز مثل ادب تشان وكذلك سياسات نزع
الكربون كربون ليس بامكانه من يعتمدوها
ربما لان الجهات
بسبب غياب اليقين بالسوق خصوصا عندما
يتعلق الامر بطلب طويل الامد هم لا يريدون
الالتزام بهذه العقود طويله الامد لانهم
لديهم تعهد واضح تماما سيده
ساتمنى منك فقط الاختصار في اجاباتك حتى
نتمكن من تقسيم الوقت بينك وبين الدكتور
الحج ونستفيد من تواجدكما في عده
محاور خلال هذه الحلقه اعود اليك دكتور
الحجي سمعت ما ذكرته الدكتوره
رزاييفا يعني اوروبا تتجه لتنويع موردي
الطاقه والسؤال ان العديد من هؤلاء
الموردين موجودون في منطقتنا كيف يمكن
للدول العربيه للاستفاده من هذه الازمه ان
صح التعبير سمعنا ضيف من قطر يتحدث بانهم
يريدون عقود طويله الاجل احد الضيوف تحدث
عن الجزائر وقال بانها ربما لا يمكن ان
تفي بالغرض لانها لا يمكن ان تزيد من
الانتاج ما مدى دقه ذلك خاصه وانا نعرف
باننا نيجيريا تريد مد خطوط عبر
قاره افريقيا وصولا للجزائر الى غايه
اوروبا ناهيك عن الغاز المسال ايضا عن
طريق البحر نود ان تشرح لنا خارطه الدول
العربيه ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط والعربيه
موجوده في افريقيا ايضا كيف يمكنها
الاستفاده من هذه الازمه ان صح التعبير
ماذا عن حسبتها في ذلك
تحديد الوقت مهم في هذه الحاله
اذا كان السؤال كالتالي هل اوروبا الان
تستورد 20% من وارداتها من روسيا هل
تستطيع استبدال ذلك في شهر الصيف القادم
او في شهور الصيف القادمه لا هل تستطيع
استبدال ذلك في الشتاء القادم لا هل
تستطيع فعل ذلك في السنه القادمه لا متى
تستطيع التغيير متى تستطيع الاستغناء
بالكامل عن روسيا اولا عندنا في قطر قطر
تحاول الان زياده انتاجها من 77 مليون طن
الى 126 بحدود عام 2016/2027 نحن نتكلم عن
عده سنوات الجزائر تستطيع زياده الانتاج
قليلا ولكن الكميه قليله على كل الحالات
ليبيا تصدر كميات قليله ولكن لا يتوقع ان
يكون هناك اي زياده موضوع مصر واسرائيل
الكميه محدوده جدا موضوع الغاز النيجيري
في رايي لن يتحقق هذا الانبوب الانبوب نعم
هناك محاولات شديده ولكن
كبيره للمد هذا الانبوب ولكن هذا الانبوب
لن يتحقق من الافضل لنيجيريا ان تتجه الى
الغاز المسال بدلا من هذا الانبوب البلد
التي تستطيع زياده الانتاج الان بغير قطر
هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن حتى
هذه الكميات محدوده لذلك
الطلب على الغاز والغاز سيكون كبيرا خلال
السنوات القادمه وسترتفع اسعاره بشكل يجعل
ازمه اوروبا مستمره لانه حتى لو وفرت
الامدادات كما ذكرتي ستكون التكلفه عاليه
على كل الحالات
الان التاثير هذه الازمه باعتقادي كيف
يمكن ان تكون على اقتصادات الدول العربيه
سواء المصادره للنفط او الغاز او غيرها
بشكل عام نرى هناك بعض الانشطه الان
والتوجه الالغاز وراينا بالامس الحديث عن
موضوع غاز غزه غزه مارين والعوده له وجدنا
هناك حديث عن موضوع غاز لبنان احتمال
سوريا اجت حسنه علاقات مع الدول الاخرى
فواضح ان هناك نشاط حول هذا الموضوع لان
الكل يدرك ان موضوع الغاز اصبح مهم من
وجهه نظرنا ان الغاز ليس جسرا للمستقبل
حتى نتحول الى الطاقه المتجدده الجغاز هو
المستقبل وعلينا ان ندرك امر اخر مجهول في
المنطقه ان هناك شيء اسمه خط الغاز العربي
موجود موجود يمتد من مصر لحد الحدود
التركيه في سوريا
يمكن استغلال هذا هذا الامر كان هناك
مشروع من قطر وايران
انبوب غاز من حقل الشمال
وحق البارس الايراني الى لرافته بخط الغاز
العربي وامداد اوروبا به ولكن هي التي
منعت هذا الخط كما اوقفت خط العربي فهناك
حلول كثيره بالنسبه لاوروبا ولكن هذه
الحلول تتطلب باعاده توزيع الدوري السياسي
لعده دول
اعود اليك سيده رزاييفه في هذه الازمه
هناك طرفان الطرف المتضرر اوروبا لكن هناك
الطرف الذي سبب هذه الازمه هو الحديث نعم
روسيا كيف باعتقادك هل تاثرت هي اصلا هذه
الازمه وكيف تاثرت بها اوروبا خفضت الى
15% والدتها من روسيا لكن رئيس الرئيس
الروسي يقول بان ميزانيه بلادهم مستقره
تضخم في ادنى مستوياته وهو اقل بكثير من
دول في الغرب ومراكز ابحاث اشارت في
الواقع في مارس الماضي الى ان روسيا حققت
مكاسب تقدر باكثر من 66 مليار دولار من
صادرات الوقود الاحفوري منذ فبراير 2022
ورغم هذا يتحدث الامريكيون عن تراجع
ايرادات النفط الروسي بنس به 50% كيف
ترينه انت في هذه المعادله ماذا خسرت
روسيا ماذا كانت تكلفه هذه الازمه على
روسيا
روسيا بالتاكيد خاسره الكثير عندما يتعلق
الامر بصادرات الغاز الطبيعي المسال لانها
فقدت اهم سوق وهو سوق الاوروبي وليس هناك
السوق واحد بامكانه ان يكون بديلا عن
السوق الاوروبي بالنسبه لروسيا خسرت
اربعين في المئه وذلك من خلال
اذن السوق الصيني او اي سوق اخر ليس
بكانهم ان
يستبدلوا او يكون بديلا بالنسبه لهذه
العائدات للغاز الطبيعي التي تتوجه او
كانت تتوجه لاوروبا
تحاول ان تنوع مصادرها واسواقها وتحاول ان
تجد
مصادر متعدده واسواق متعدده لتستبدلها
بسوق لتستبدل سوقا واحدا اذا يتعلق الامر
بالغاز المسلى ليس بامكان روسيا ان تعوض
عن ما كانت تحصل عليه من الاسواق
الاوروبيه فيما يتعلق الامر بالنفط
وصادرات النفط روسيا لم تخسر ماديا الكثير
نعم هناك سقف للاسعار بالنسبه للنفط وكذلك
منتجات النفط ذات الصله بالنسبه
للعملاء يدفعون 25% اقل بالنسبه
للنفط الروسي
مقارنه باي سقف اخر لكن روسيا زادت وبشكل
كبير جدا صادراتها المتعلقه بالنفط
بالمنتجات النفطيه وعملاء الروسيا هم
الهند
والاسواق الهنديه الكبيره لدينا كذلك
الصين لدينا كذلك تركيا
الدول الشرق الاوسطيه ودول اخرى خارجه
اطار السوق الاوروبي بالنسبه لصادرات
النفط لا اعتقد ان روسيا تاثرت كثيرا
بالنسبه لصادره لكن بصفات عامه وعندما
تحدث بصفه عامه
بالتاكيد
الميزانيه
الروسيه تحصل على عائدات اقل بالنسبه لكل
من الغاز والنفط في السنوات القليله
القادمه خصوصا عندما تحدث عن سنه او سنتين
قادمتين سنجد ان هناك محاولات بالنسبه
لروسيا لتجد اسواقا جديد وذلك لتعوض ما
خسرته من احجام الصادرات التي كانت توجهها
للاسواق الاوروبيه
لو تكرمت ما رايك في هذه النقطه روسيا
ماذا عن بدائلها للحفاظ على ايراداتهم تص
دير الغاز الطبيعي هل تستطيع باعتقادك عبر
تركيا او تصدير الى الصين عبر خط قوه
انابيب سيبيريا ربما كافيان لتعويض
الخساره
روسيا لعبه لم ينتبه لها المحللون وهي ان
اغلب الغاز الذي كان يذهب بالانابيب كان
عقود طويله المدى بعضها وجدوا سبب قانوني
لانهائه وبعضها لما انتهى رفضوا التجديد
والسبب هو التحول الى الغاز
صادرات روسيا من الغاز المسائل الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي زادت
فهم عوضوا عن التخفيض طبعا ليس بالكاميرا
الكبير ولكن عوضوا عن جزء من التخفيض
بتصدير الغاز المسار والذي يباع بسعر اعلى
في هذه الحاله ولكن بالنسبه للنفط اسمحي
لي بس توضيح فكره ان اصرار وزيره الخزانه
الامريكيه على انخفاض ايرادات النفط
الروسيه وكما ذكرت زميلتي من لندن هذه
بروباجاندا لانه تصوري انه لما فرضوا
السقف الشعري يوم 5 ديسمبر 2022 بعد
اسبوعين كانت تتكلم عن خفض الايرادات
الروسيه بسبب سقف الشهري ولكن عندما تبيع
الشركه النفط حتى تصبح اموال هذا النفط
ضرائب عند الحكومه تستغرق سته الى تسعه
شهور
فواضح لعدم قول الحقيقه في الموضوع من او
من البدايه هم يريدون ان يقولوا ذلك ولكن
حتى تتحول هذه الاموال الى خزانه الدوله
تستغرق وقتا طويلا
لم يؤثر في الاسواق على الاطلاق ولكن الذي
اثر هو تكاليف الشحن الضخم
والتخفيض الكبير اكبر تخفيض في شعر النفط
الروسي حصل قبل ما يتكلموا بالعقوبات وقبل
ان يتكلموا بالنفط بالصقف الشعري لماذا
لان تكاليف الشحن من شمال روسيا الى الصين
والهند اضعاف مضاعفه من تكاليف شحنه الى
اوروبا فالتخفيض سببه الاساسي هو تكاليف
الشحن
الان اذا ما تحدثنا بشكل اكبر كيف ستتاثر
اذا استمرت طبعا هذه الازمه ولم يتم ايجاد
حل سياسي للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كيف
ستتاثر خارطه الطاقه العالميه
وشبكاتها اذا استمرت اذن هذه الازمه في
اعتقادك
اول امر حصل تغير كبير في اتجاهات التجاره
الدوليه في النفط والغاز جزء من هذا
التحول سيصبح دائما على كل الحالات بعباره
اخرى لو انتهت العقوبات غدا لو انتهت
الحرب غدا وانتهت العقوبات غدا لن ترجع
الامور الى ما كانت عليه على الاطلاق هناك
جزء من التحول اصبح ابدي انتهى الامر
الاخر ان هناك اشكاليه كبيره في موضوع ان
بعض الدول التابعه لخصر ذكرت زميلتي في
لندن موضوع الدول الشرق الاوسطيه وجدت ان
استيراد من المواد النفطيه من روسيا ارخص
من ان تقوم بانتاج النفط وتكريره وبالتالي
يمكنها تخفيض الانتاج بسهوله هذا احد
الاثار الكبيره التي نتجت عن هذا الموضوع
دكتوره تتفقين مع الدكتور الحجي بان هناك
بعض الامور لا يمكن ان تعود الى مكانه في
سابق عهدها يعني اي حل سياسي للازمه
الاوكرانيه هل سيؤدي الى اعتقادك الى
تغيير ربما المعادلات المعادلات عفوا
الاوروبيه والغربيه الراهنه في موضوع
الطاقه وحتى الموقف من الغاز الروسي او
حتى الصيني ام ليس بالضروره
نعم اتفق مع زميلي نعم الوضع لن يعود الى
ما كان عليه في السابق ولن تكون لدينا
اسواق الطاقه التي كانت موجوده قبل هذا
الوضع لان هناك ما يسمى بالتحول في
المانماط المعتمده لدينا تصميم جديد
لاسواق الطاقه الذي نشهده يتمدد حاليا حتى
لو تم حل الازمات حتى لو انتهت الحرب لا
سيكون لدينا حاله اعتياديه جديده لن تكون
كمثيلتها التي كانت في السابق اذا المشكله
الاساسيه لن تكون فقط بالنسبه لسوق الغاز
المسال بالنسبه لاوروبا وانما كذلك
بالنسبه لاسواق اخرى المشكله تكمن في
تامين العرض والتوريد لان السوق سيتغير
بشكل كبير جدا هناك امكانيه ان الامور
ستكون اكثر صعوبه مما هو الامر عليه الان
لان الامر سيعتمد على زياده الطلب في اسيا
او حتى في اوروبا وعندما يكون لدينا مثل
هذا السوق فان هذا الامر سيؤدي الى تقلب
في اسعار الطاقه خصوصا اسعار الغاز
الطبيعي المسال والجهات التي تحتاج الى
هذه المصادر ستواجه هذه التقلبات في
الاسعار وبالتالي سيكون هناك منافسه فيما
يخص الشحن واحجام التي يحتاجون اليها
للغاز المسال وكذلك
المنافسه ما بين اسيا واوروبا وموردين
اخرين مثل قطر ودول اخرى واذا ما اضفنا
الى كل هذه الامور فان السياسات نزع
الكربون التي
تنتهجها اوروبا وتسعى الى تحقيقها نحن
نتحدث هنا عن
مليارات الدول الاستثمارات في الطاقات
المتجدده التي دخلت
اليها اوروبا وتحاول ان تطبقها في السنوات
القادمه اعتقد ان هذا سيؤدي الى معضله
كبيره في السوق خصوصا في السوق الاوروبي
لان هذا سيؤدي الى قضايا مضاعفه بشكل
ثلاثين لا تحتاج ان نتحدث عن التنويع
تامين الموارد
تنويع كذلك المصادر ونتحدث كذلك عن نزع
الكربون كسياسات انتهجتها الدول
دعيني اتحول للدكتور الحجي دكتور حجي يعني
الى اي حد يمكن بالفعل ان تساهم موارد
الطاقه المتجدده ربما في حل ازمه الطاقه
الاوروبيه باعتقادك
نعم ساجيب عن هذا السؤال فقط اريد ان اذكر
معلومه للمشاهد ان نفط الروسي يصل الى
الولايات المتحده النفط الروسي يصل الى
الدول الاوروبيه رغم الحظر على كل الحالات
بالنسبه للطاقه المتجدده هناك اشكاليه
كبيره بالنسبه لموضوع الغاز تظن يظن
السياسيون في اوروبا انهم بزياده
الطاقه الاستيعابيه للطاقه المتجدده انهم
سيخفضون من استهلاكهم للغاز ولكن لنعد الى
بدايه صيف 2021 لماذا بدات الازمه بدات
الازمه في بدايه الصيف عندما ارتفعت درجه
الحراره بشكل كبير في بريطانيا لماذا
ارتفعت درجه الحراره ارتفعت درجات الحراره
لانه ليس هناك رياح وبالتالي ليس هناك
طاقه رياح وبالتالي الطاقه المتجدده التي
يعتمدون عليها غير موجوده طيب ما هو
البديل البديل هو الغاش طيب الغاز من اين
سياتي
فالمشكله ان المشكله الاخرى انهم كلما
توسعوا في الطاقه المتجدده لانها متقطعه
تحتاج الى طاقه اخرى كبديل عندما تنقطع
هذه الطاقه ما هو البديل في هذه الحاله
اما الفحم او الغاز فهم لا يستطيعون
استخدام الطاقه المتجدده فقط لوحدها بدون
الغاز والفحم على كل الحالات بعد سنه بعد
سنتين بعد ثلاثه بعد اربعه المشكله الاخرى
انهم لا ياخذون في الحسبان ما رايناه الان
في السنتين الاخيرتين وهو ان بعض سياسات
التغير المناخي فشلت وبعضها سيفشل ما هو
البديل في هذه الحاله ضمن فكره التغير
المناخي البديل هو الغاز
من اين سياتي هذا الغاز اذا المشكله
ستستمر بالنسبه لاوروبا باعتقادك ما
البدائل الممكنه لها ان عدتها في عجاله
الحل الوحيد هو
ايجاد صيغه سياسيه ما لعودتها لاستيراد
بعض الغاز الروسي لانه مستوى الحياه مستوى
المعيشه في اوروبا انخفض في السنتين
الاخيرتين وجدنا حتى انهم دول يطالبوا
الناس انه يتغسلوا في ماء بارد او انهم
يتروشوا كل يوم الا يوم او يعني انخفاض في
مستوى المعيشه اشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور انس
الحجي الباحث والخبيره الدولي في مجال
الطاقه كنت معنا من دالاس كما اشكر من
لندن
كبيره الباحثين في معهد اوكسفورد لدراسه
الطاقات حلقتنا هذه من برنامج القصه بقي
نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله نبقيه بقصه جديده
الاثنين القادم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]